C'C'est le moment de notre panel
popolitique Hélènene Buzzetti,
MiMichel C. Auger et on ajoute
avavec nous ce soir Frédéric
BoBoily, politologue de à
l'l'université de l'Alberta.
BoBonsoir.
D'D'abord, ce point de presse
jujuste avant qu'on entre en
onondes, Justin Trudeau a décidé
dede lever l'application de cete
loloi sur les mesures d'urgence.
LaLa loi a été sanctionnée, vote
etet adoptée par la chambre lun.
C'C'est rendu autour du Sénat de
dédébattre là-d-dessus. Voici
popourquoi il décide de la
reretirer.
JUJUTSIN TRUDEAU,
prpremier ministre du Canada
- - Aujourd'hui, après s avoir
sosoigneusement examiné
lala situation, on constate
ququ'on n'est plus en situation
d'd'urgence. C'est pourquoi
lele gouvernement fédéral met tn
àà l la Loi sur les mesures
d'd'urgence. On juge maintenant
quque les lois en place sont
susuffisantes pour assurer
lala sécurité de la population.
EÉvidemment, on va continuer de
sosoutenir les autorités locales
etet provinciales, au besoin.
- - Alors, Hélènene, c'est
ababsolument incontournable, on
avavait besoin de cette loi lun,
dedeux jours p plus tard, on n'a
plplus besoin. Qu'est-ce q qui t
papassé?
- - J'entends dans les propos de
M.M. Trudeau un désaveu trèss
sosolide envers la police
d'd'Ottawa, quand on écoute bien
totout ce qu'il dit, il dit qu'n
alallait loi actuelle, les lois
rérégulièreres qui sont suffisas
popour empêchcher le retour de e
ququi se retrouve en banlieue
d'd'Ottawa, donc les lois sont
susuffisantes pour empêchcher
l'l'implantation des manifestan,
mamais une fois qu'ils étaient
imimplantés, là, , ça nous prent
dedes outils supplémentaires por
leles déloger de là. . Ce que jn
cocomprends, c'est qu'on désavoe
lala police d'Ottawa, qui n'a ps
fafait ce qu'il fallait pour
emempêchcher cette implantations
gegens. Il y a peut-êtrtre auss,
ququoi que ce soit spéculatif, n
a a voulu éviter le vote au Sén,
ququi aurait eu lieu demain. Les
sésénateurs étant ce qu'ils son,
ilil n'y a pas vraiment de l'une
dedes parties, chacun vote comme
ilil veut et on pense que ça
n'n'aurait peut-êtrtre pas passa
n'n'aurait pas été un vote des..
vovote de confiance alors ça été
popossible que ça ne passe pas,
unune forme camouflée pour M.
TrTrudeau qu'on a voulu éviter
cecette situation embarrassante.
- - Oui, il y a des sénateurs
ininfluents, des juristes,
ququi ont dit : ce qui s'est paé
llà e est contraire à l la chare
n'n'était pas le temps d'utilisr
lala loi des mesures d'urgence.
VoVoici quelqu'un de trèss
ininfluent. Il y avait de trèss
grgros chances au Sénat, c'est s
grgrave, l'avis du gouvernement
papas mis en danger, mais ça
auaurait eu l'air très s faux. a
prpréféré avoir l'air il d'une
auautre façon, c'est-à-d-dire de
didire en 72 heures que tout s't
cacalmé, tout va bien, c'est
memerveilleux. Je pense que ça
prprouve qu'on n'avait pas beson
d'd'évoquer cette loi.
- - Ce que dit M. Trudeau, c'est
ququ'on a tous les outils pour
évéviter des blocages. C'est en
reregardant les faits, et encore
unune manifeststation à W Winni,
ilils ont un ultimatum sonont ps
etet sont revenus, les
cacamionneurs, il y a aussi en
babanlieue d'Ottawa, il y a ence
dedes camionneurs qui occupent
cecertains endroits des terrains
prprivés, ils ont l'air d'attene
dede nouvelles mobilisations, je
nene sais pas quoi, pour revenià
OtOttawa ou non, on peut peut-êe
lala montrer, ce sont les trois
lilieux qui sont en rouge ici, l
y y a aussi cette menace de
blbloquer un pont qui est crucil
popour le Île-du-Prince-Édouard,
lele pont de la confédération,
c'c'est une manifestation qui
sesemble êtrtre en train de
s's'organiser dans ce secteur.Ça
veveut dire que le mouvement de
mamanifestation ne s'est pas
ététeint, mais on pense qu'on et
cocomplètetement capable de se
papasser de cette loi sur les
memesures.
- - M. Trudeau la lyoce, la mene
esest encore là, , maintenant, a
leles outils nécessaires avec ls
lolois actuelles pour de faire
faface a ces manifestations.
IlIl y en a eu à E Edmonton, coe
lala Saskatchewan également, pe-
êêtrtre aussi que du côtété des
mamanifestants, on va peut-êtrte
rerevoir également la façon dont
mamanifeste pour éviter justemet
d'd'avoir l'air de vouloir étabr
unune occupation, bloquer des
poponts, et donc les
mamanifestations également bon..
leles manifestantsts vont tenir
cocompte de tout ça. J'ajouterai
unune chose aussi dans le
spspéculatif qui a été évoqué pr
HéHélènene Buzzetti, générationi
apappelait également sur le moyn
teterme, les considérations
papartisanes de la part de M.
TrTrudeau, c'est-à-d-dire qu'onu
quque la loi sur les mesures
d'd'urgence mettait de donner un
cecertain ciment au camp
coconservateur je parle de la
fifille conservatrice au sens
lalarge, on l'a vu en Alberta,
JaJason Kenney tu es trèss
rarapidement sur la dénonciation
dede la loi. Pense que du côtéts
lilibéraux, on commençait à
s's'apercevoir qu'il y avait cet
efeffet long est prévu que ça
dodonnait une de momentum pour n
nonouveau souffle à c certains
coconsommateurs existe peut-être
lele temps de reculer parce que
leles conséquences imprévues
pepeuvent devenir difficiles à
gégérer pour le camp libéral.
- - J'aimerais qu'on parle
mamaintenant de la façon dont cs
mamanifestants, les gens liés à
grgrands mouvements, la façon dt
ilil appréhende la politique
cacanadienne, la comprennent, en
didiscutent entre eux, parce qun
a a l'impression, aller à l la
gagauche à d droite, on nage en
plpleine confusion, à u un poinl
quque du bureau la gouverneure
gégénérale, on déduit mettre un
memessage pour dire : on dément
totoute rumeur prétendant.
LeLes manifestants parlaient d'e
esespècece de vote de non de
coconfiance pour envoyer une
pépétition et signer son nom. Ee
didisait que ce n'était pas exa.
C'C'est un exemple parmi d'autr.
IlIls ont l'air confus aussi avc
leles lois américaines, on parle
dudu conjoint d'une des leadersu
momouvement de camionneurs,
ququi plaide le premier amendemt
dede l'or de son audience sur sa
liliberté sous caution. On a pae
auau Canada. Mêmeme l'juge dans
rerevenait pas. Aux États-Unis,
c'c'est ce qu'évoque M. Trump.
CoComment vous comprenez cette
coconfususion? Pourquoi il y a
auautant de confusions?
- - D'abord, si généralisé dansa
popopulation de mal comprendre s
sosocio-politiques, n'est pas
prpropre à l la droite ou
cacamionneurs. C'est sûr r que t
tetentant en regardant ça de die
quque voilà l l'effet du discous
trtrumpistes qui a percoler dans
l'l'esprit de ces gens. Je ne vs
plplus largement, je pense que
c'c'est généralement au Canadaùu
ilil y a beaucoup d'influence
amaméricaine est particulièreret
auauprès s des Canadiens anglai,
ananglophone, qui contrairement
auaux Québécois francophones n't
papas cette de la langue, s'il
dadans cette culture américainet
reregarde la télé, il baigne das
leleur imaginaire américain et
dodonc ils en arrivent à n ne ps
totout à f fait faire la distinn
enentre les deux réalités. Je
didirais qu'il faut faire
atattention de n'est pas propreà
lala droite de faire cela, le
trtrumpisme, on a vu des gens qi
scscandaient... un peu comme on
avavait fait avec Hillary Clintn
auaux États-Unis, mais ce n'est
papas propre à l la droite, regr
lala gauche aussi, la gauche qui
imimporte ici au Canada lecture
papar exemple racial de les
tetensions sociales dans la
totoxicité, alors que tensions
sosociales au Canada n'ont
ababsolument rien à v voir avecs
EÉtats-Unis, cette idéologie woe
auaussi qu'il vient beaucoup des
EÉtats-Unis, je pense que c'est
auautant à g gauche qu'à d droil
y y a une espècece d'amalgame qi
esest fait avec les États-Unis,n
imimporte toutes sortes de
coconcepts américains qui ne
cocollent pas nécessairement à a
réréalité canadienne.
- - Est-ce que c'est encore plus
fofort ce qu'Hélènene vient de
dédécrire dans l'Ouest canadien,
esest il y a un glissement de
peperte d'identité Canadiens, on
sese voit davantage des
AmAméricains.
- - Ah! bon, influence américaie
dudu coude et notamment de
l'l'Alberta est là d depuis les
dédébuts mêmemes de l'Alberta, n
tatant que province. Ce n'est ps
nénécessairement nouveau. Il fat
sese rappeler d'ailleurs quand
StStephen Harper est arrivé au
popouvoir, on l'accusait Denis u
coconservatisme, ce n'était pasn
cocompliment qu'on disait qu'il
ététait comme George W. Bush, qi
vovoulait faire la guerre au
MoMoyen-Orient. Ce qui est nouvu
jojour de focusser il y a une
cecertaine radicalisation dans
cecette influence la droite,
c'c'est-à-d-dire qu'elle est
prprésente, il peut y avoir une
ininfluence tout à f fait normae
enentre la droite américaine eta
drdroite canadienne, passage
d'd'idées de la frontièrere quit
êêtrtre normale, mais aujourd'h,
c'c'est une question aussi d'une
cecertaine radicalisation et de
coconfusions du discours qui étt
prprobablement pas là a auparavt
etet qui est engendré notamment
papar le fait aussi des médias
sosociaux et la rapidité aussi
avavec laquelle cela se fait. Il
fafaut pas oublier aussi le rôle
dedes médias traditionnels je
pepense notamment à F Fox News,i
a a donné beaucoup de temps
d'd'antenne à t toutes les
mamanifestations, donc cette
cocombinaison faite en sorte qun
sese retrouve dans un état à l a
fofois de radicalisation sur les
frfranges de la droite et de
coconfusions idéologiques qui
s's'étend un peu plus.
- - Vous êtetes basé en Alberta.
EsEst-ce que vous constatez
auaujourd'hui vous, des Albertas
ququi consomme Fox News
prprincipalement comme source
d'd'information?
- - Non, pas nécessairement juse
FoFox News, je veux dire que c't
unune influence que l'on s'empae
didifférent canaux est aussi une
ininfluence qui peut se manifesr
enen raison du délai proximité i
esest à l la fois géographique s
auaussi qu'économique, c'est-à--
didire qu'on a les mêmemes
prpréoccupations dans l'Ouest
sosouvent qu'on retrouve dans
l'l'Ouest américain, par exemple
hihistoire des convois de camio,
leles premiers que j'ai vus, ily
a a eu celui en 2019 en Alberta
ququi était descendue vers Otta,
mamais il y en avait eu égalemet
dudu côtété de l'Oregon qui état
dadans sa nature mêmeme exactemt
ququi était dans sa nature mêmee
exexactement pareille, de 2018,
202019 et 2020 également, des
dede camions, on allait contestr
dedes mesures en matièrere de le
cocontre les changements
clclimatiques.
- - Comment ça a un impact sur a
popolitique canadienne, sur les
paparties politiques au Canada?
- - D'abord, l'influence
amaméricaine est là, , on ne pet
papas la nier, les gens aux Éta-
UnUnis et des séries policièrers
quque c'est les mains convois au
CaCanada anglais, il n'y a pas e
DiDistrict 31. Ça fait quelque
chchose que c'est pas le juste e
prpremier amendement, cinquièmee
auaussi qu'on connaît t bien. Ms
ilil reste qu'on a vu dans les
mamanifestations d'Ottawa et
aiailleurs aussi des drapeaux de
lala campagne de Trump, ce n'est
papas rien. J'ai cherché toute a
jojournée les cotes d'écoute de
FoFox News Canada, paraît t quee
chchiffre ne existe pas, mais
c'c'est clair que des gens comme
TuTucker Carlson, qui vendait ds
T-T-shirts des camionneurs,
c'c'est sûr r que ça une influee
auau Canada, c'est sur une frane
raradicale, c'est très s clair,s
çaça frange radicale s'est
mamanifesté à O Ottawa au course
lala manifestation des trois
sesemaines, ce n'est pas tout le
momonde de cette manifestation i
esest dans une frange radicale,
mamais les... en été. Il y a
d'd'autres venant des États-Uni,
mamais aussi venant de quelque
chchose d'internautes Canada,
raradicalisation, la faveur des
memesures sanitaires n'est pas e
seseul pays où ça arrive.
- - Comment vous voyez se tradue
cocomment qu'elle ait accès s às
papartis politiques, il y a une
tetentation d'aller chercher ces
gegens, allez prendre cette cole
etet la tourner à s son avantag.
- - Il y a une espècece de situn
ququi rend la droite plus la mo,
M.M. Boyon parlait tout à l l'h,
onon le voit et ce n'est pas que
prpropre aux parties, mais on le
vovoit, réduit mêmeme au Québecl
sese en second place chez les
frfrancophones, Parti conservatr
ququi reprend les devants selonn
dedernier sondage bien
coconfortablement devant les
lilibéraux, on verra si ça dure.
MaMais il y a une espècece de
coconjecture qui fait que les gs
enen ce moment ont une fatigue
papandémiques très s évidente, c
ilil se traduit par plusieurs pr
unune colèrere, donc tout d'un ,
ilils sentent que le parti...
leles Parti conservateur au sens
lalarge sont mieux à m mêmeme de
poporter ce message et donc on e
vovoit que ça vient gonfler leus
inintentions de vote. M. Boyer
avavait raison de dire que M.
TrTrudeau a fait cette lecture t
c'c'est ce qui l'amènene à t toe
susuite se rétracte. Ceci dit, .
dudu Héma-Québec va beaucoup pls
rarapidement aller aux urnes et
popourra peut-êtrtre encaisser -
dedessus, alors que les
coconsommateurs Ottawa, on n'a s
unune élection pour demain mati,
etet donc peut-êtrtre que font n
mamauvais calcul stratégique de
totout miser là-d-dessus, sur ce
cacale colèrere, camionneurs, e.
PePeut-êtrtre que dans deux ans,
énénonce restera plus grand-choe
etet on va se souvenir que l'le
grgrand parti de la loi et l'ore
n'n'a pas voulu rétablir l'ordrà
OtOttawa.
- - Je vous ai beaucoup parlé de
JeJean Charest, qui pourrait se
poporter comme candidat. Mais il
sesemble que M. Harper serait pt
àà l lui bloquer la route cette
fofois-ci.
- - M. Harper est très s influet
dadans le Parti conservateur, il
pepeut faire trois ou quatre
tétéléphones discrets, mais il t
clclair que ce n'est pas le même
gegenre de consommateurs, c'est
clclair que depuis 2007, le
rrèglglement du déséquilibre fil
quque M. Charest a promis en
babaisse d'impôtsts, M. Harper e
sesentir le dindon de la farce
dadans cette histoire il n'y a s
d'd'atomes crochus entre des
hohommes, il y a des gens qui ot
apappuyé, qui disent que M. Harr
n'n'est plus là, , et à
l'l'international, de voir parce
ququ'il est quand mêmeme capable
fafaire savoir ce qu'elle aime t
cece qu'il ne pas de façon
didiscrètete, il est très s eff.
- - C'est tout le temps qu'on
avavait. Séduction est
papassionnante sur les flancs
amaméricaines, sono manifestant,
susur les